chad and jt are boys are they back
well yeah they're there they they're
they went to a uh well the title of the
video is a peace treaty
between skaters and city officials so
let's check it out
into uh public comments on non-agenda
items
uh what up council my name is chad
kroger
first off wow this paedemic is still
pretty crazy huh
pedemic i mean seriously what is going
on
anyways you guys look good tans are
popping
nice yeah so back when chris first
struck and got tom hanks
things were tough but things got even
tougher
when the city committed what can only be
described as an act of war against the
youth
and i think you know what i'm talking
about you guys
dumped sand in the skate park
it hurt oh yeah almost as bad as when
mia silinski
dumped santa in my heart in ninth grade
when she decided to go to europe for two
weeks
and i'm all for safety but this is a bit
rash
and let me be clear i'm cool not
shredding crete during lockdown
i'm cool not working i don't even have a
job but i'm not
cool with sand in the skate parks
we don't have skaters have been bullied
for centuries it's unfair
can you imagine the city dumping sand on
the tennis courts at pelican hill
these guys are just such dicks skaters
don't even have an emoji i mean you got
one for surfers salsa dancers
even skiers and thankfully skateparks
are open again and we are psyched
but i can still hear the sound of sand
crunching in my bearings
skateboarders need this is a bit some
new people of course
these guys do this all the time yeah
they're going to sit down to [ __ ] with
people
i still think my hands down my favorite
uh
moment of these guys ever was shooting
down laura lover oh yeah that was great
just it's like hey why don't you guys
come over here why
some people really think these guys are
for real i think that's hilarious
restitution from the city restitution
that we can all be our way
out of this conundrum and there's no
better person to propose this olive
branch
than my dog jt oh jt here comes all
right
go ahead what up council
i don't have an actual olive branch that
was a metaphor for peace
i'm a rollerblader it's rare to see a
blader and skater united for the same
cause
but chad and i learned long ago that we
are stronger together
i want to push beyond the sand episode
and get to a place where city officials
and riders feel like they can coexist at
wahoo's once again
in ancient times a general after gaining
dominion
would do a ritual dance with his enemy
we need a gesture like that from the
city
that lets us know you hear hang on on
that i it's worth just noting that
we do not have a skate park we did not
dump anything not even the right time
but
they're they're in the wrong place it's
not even the right thing they're in the
wrong town
picture that has been shown is a
different city so
anyway all right we'll go to the next uh
oh i don't like okay look dude
wait wait look i get married i i
it's the wrong city does th but does
this guy not understand
i mean obviously he doesn't but this guy
should understand
right that like obviously there's some
kind of playful trolling going on this
is obviously
why you got to be such a prick like why
do you got to be so
you know like i understand you're
wasting time whatever but like this
guy's being very
this is the kind of thing that can ruin
a small level politician's career
because it's like
wouldn't you just kind of laugh it off
just in case cameras are white you go
all right guys look i get what you're
doing but it's not you're not even the
right town
we boys think that you can serve as an
ambassador for the rider
and city official community that is why
we are asking you
mr mayor to drop into the san clemente
skate park bowl
it would be a huge message to riders all
over that we can trust you
don't be afraid just dip your shoulder
commit to the drop like you commit to
civil service
ride it out it'll be over in a few
seconds
if you brick it we'll have the same
medical team there from the jake brown
accident
and there is no more symbolic date for
this to happen
than september 4th 2020.
the day tony hawk pro skater 1 and 2
comes out
on multiple platforms smart this speech
was paid for by activision
thank you
[Laughter]
okay that's pretty great that's pretty
awesome all right thank you skate or die
there you go all right so uh any other
public comments in the and that's how it
uh um
how it ended that's [ __ ] amazing
skate or die
folks i love the i like these guys man
what they do is very pure there's not a
lot of that left you know what i mean
there's not a lot of just pure
like i i'm just here and i'm just being
stupid
and i'm not there's no agenda i'm not
here to [ __ ]
scream at anybody i'm not there you know
what i like about them
they're not trying to [ __ ] own
anybody
they're not trying to win
at anything you know what i mean they're
just showing up and they're just getting
their dumb footage and they leave
they were in the wrong city which made
it even better
and it you know it did take this guy a
while so i'm gonna have to walk up to
him and go
hey that's not the right city that
they're talking about i wonder honestly
if that was even a bit
like i wonder if they honestly just went
to the wrong place